thanks so much Emily so I will assure
you all disclaimer that our slides won't
be as graph heavy as Andreas's and we
won't be talking about staged rollouts
and what not kind of like Emily but over
the head and over the head but we're
here talking about content and content
as it relates to YouTube and you know
I'm on the YouTube end and who better to
bring then and youtuber himself you're
all the way from Boston and we're gonna
be talking about mobile gaming content
and kind of the rise of how users have
been consuming content around on YouTube
around this category so I'll do some
slides let's see about kind of like
where mobile gaming has come from right
so obviously a huge evolution from kind
of linear puzzle games like a Tetris -
all of a sudden you know a worldwide
kind of interactive PvP game such as
clash rail and when talking about these
kind of games in the way that content is
consumed they obviously have very
different characteristics replayability
kind of iterative game modes which gives
folks like Tim a lot more content to
make once a game is both launched and
has DLC coming out you know regularly so
you know mobile gaming on YouTube has
really seen a huge increase in the past
two years as far as hours watched is a
main metric that we use at YouTube not
so much views anymore
more just total you know empirical hours
or time watched has just completely
blown up and I think games like the
supercell games clash of clans clash
royale games like Pokemon go which is a
huge spike last year in other games like
puzzles & Dragons or lineage or Angry
Birds have really led to this sudden
increase on both content produced in
content consumed so this is kind of just
a brief timeline of how you know watch
time on YouTube has been really you know
expanding since all the way in 2015 so
as you can see you know the the launch
of clash Royale kind of led to a little
bit of a spike and then last year you
know Pokemon go was kind of a phenomenal
event that we've been tracking which led
to a sudden you know peak the slope is
still very much you know steady and we
see a steady increase in the way people
are consuming games and it's really
encouraging just to see you know
creators also adopt you know
mobile-first strategies in the way that
their channel DNA is is composed so ash
to you so I was kind of doing some
digging uh you know and and I think
September second what almost three years
ago was the first time that you really
you know took a stab at uploading
YouTube content can you tell me a little
bit about what was going through your
head when you were you know thinking
what is what is the first video before
hitting the publish button
sure yes so I had absolutely no
experience in a mobile gaming or be in
in YouTube certainly so I lacked the
technical expertise along with just the
networking that you would think one one
should have if they want to establish if
you want to endeavour to establish a
really good YouTube channel so I didn't
have any of that I had really bad
quality to boot and I just uploaded a
few videos just for my it was for clash
of clans at the time and it was just for
my guilt my clan inside the the game
just to cover special events that we
were hosting and now three years later
I'm here on the stage with you somehow I
don't know how the heck it happened but
so obviously like you said you know your
content started off I'll be kind of a
dick here and say it was kind of rough
you know just say the least I was
watching it and it was it was pretty bad
and and and now a great host you know
now that now you have a very beautiful
intro and clearly I think directionally
things have kind of changed but can you
kind of tell me like what is necessarily
changed but like within the game like
you know what's giving you more
encouragement to continue uploading yeah
so I think you were being kind it was
absolutely awful you can see I didn't
even utilize the full the full landscape
mode but you know I think that I think
that when I started I I just want to do
it purely as a small little hobby I
didn't even think it was possible for
someone like me when I started my
youtube channel I was like 32 I was
playing with like 16 year old it's kind
of creepy I know but you know there
wasn't I didn't think that I had that
infectious personality that could that
could certainly take off so I just had
you know I said really really minimal
goals for myself just learning one
new thing a week in trying to apply it
to my channel as I like to tackle bigger
things in life no matter what you're
doing is try to continue to get better
at it so that was really you know that
led to not even close to where I see
myself right now as the final product so
I'm still kind of continuing on those
trends but yeah just one thing at a time
and you're up to like five hundred
thousand we're closing in we're closing
in yeah yeah so certainly not the
biggest in the ecosystem but I've
managed to do it you know just to inject
a little bit of pride I've managed to do
it kind of sticking to myself and not
being someone who I'm not and covering
more strategic elements of games rather
than being a big personality yeah so you
know in your opinion there's obviously
tons of kind it's very subjective you
know like really what makes good content
and what did you find really you know
did you stick to and and I guess is this
the game subject matter was this a
certain format you know what what do you
really define is good content and
content that your audience really not
only watch for the first time but
continued watching yes so it's
definitely different for every
individual and in every content creator
and every developer what kind of content
you're looking for for your game but for
me I've always just strived to make
content that I would want to watch
really basic and cliche but I just you
know I think it takes a lot of grit when
you're starting out in YouTube just as
you're starting out as a game developer
where you know you're not gonna
experience as much as people like to
believe their channel is gonna blow up
one day and they're just gonna be a
millionaire it just doesn't work like
that you have to kind of get through
that first year or even more sometimes
of seeing stagnant if any growth so what
I think makes good talk content is being
true to yourself and at the same time
not being afraid to be transparent and
also be honest so you know I've always
built my channel around even if I have
good relationships with all the
developers that I that I work with I
think that I'm honest and I really love
opinion pieces if you if you will so I
just think making your content worth
watching no matter what that no matter
what that vehicle is to get it there it
is really important what do you do you
differentiate yourself from everybody
out there making content
the same games you know so I think being
a little bit unique but staying true to
yourself kind of working within your
personality to make content something
I've noticed is you know some of these
top grossing games oftentimes don't have
any or very low viewership on the
YouTube platform yeah you have any kind
of intuition or kind of hypothesis
around that you know games that a ton of
people play and spend and you know
clearly come back after the first try
but you know they really aren't watching
any kind of content like what what are
some things you really think lead to
that or some of the problems there yes
so the developers that I work with have
really valued community almost to its
detriment at some times but it pays off
in the long term some some developers
are lucky enough to have billions of
marketing dollars if not hundreds of
millions or millions and those type of
games no matter in my opinion no matter
what they do they're gonna succeed
because they're throwing so much money
like mobile strike no offensive mobile
strikes developers here but like if you
throw millions and millions and millions
of dollars into the game of course
you're gonna generate users foster rank
high on the App Store thus you know
continue to get that momentum but I
think that what a lot of developers miss
is how to use content creators
strategically to grow that ecosystem
around their game and I think they do it
in the wrong way a lot of times we'll
talk more about yeah yeah so you touched
briefly on the detriment to sometimes of
you know growing community and I have to
guess like negative feedback and yeah
kids on Facebook saying yeah yeah yeah
so the games I cover I mean they can't
put out a tweet about their game without
getting the top tweets or your game
sucks it's dying whatever but that's a
good thing because people are so
passionate about it it's better than
pretending out a tweet about your game
and getting absolutely no response right
now so I kind of want to touch on the
nuances right of like capturing mobile
content like I come from the the PC
console world so I think the path was a
little bit clearer when certain hardware
like capture cards were released and you
know encoding software and the way to
just to record both like vodka and live
streams it was a lot more commonly known
right but when it comes to mobile
content and how you capture it can you
talk a little bit about like your setup
and maybe some of the nuances of how you
can
captured from a from a device or for me
like your tablet or phone and how you
actually eventually get the video
content that you're recording to your
computer and up on YouTube sure I think
this is a hurdle that's becoming easier
and easier to clear with technology kind
of moving in the direction where you can
easily record your device however I
think it's it's really paramount for
developers to work with content creators
to help kind of increase their value
right their production value and you
know you can record right from your
screen now with a lot of different apps
a lot of mirror type apps me personally
I use a device hardware called Elgato
where you can just use you know a
lightning cable or HDMI cable and just
hook right up directly so I mean there's
a lot of ways to do it
even with emulators but it's up to
basically try to find the highest
quality way that you can possibly a
understand and B afford to use well I
think it's kind of ironic cuz a lot of
people are consuming the mobile game
content on their phones but the
broadcaster's you're still pretty much
wired to ya a very static kind of setup
right indeed until it kind of like Wi-Fi
capabilities and some things might be
able to shift or storage space you on a
phone you know you're still kind of
locked to a very static setup yeah yeah
it's true and I think that hopefully
will kind of move in the right direction
but yeah that's kind of where it is
right now so let's talk about kind of
like ways developers have embrace
youtubers I kind of going left to right
someone like a you know the largest
YouTube creator PewDiePie head you know
worked with a developer in order to make
his own game I think supercell is a
quite a good job using you know their
their talent as beacons to both
announced game-mode launches or new
cards or anything else going on and then
kind of like best fiends model where
youtubers and influencers are actually
built into the games and your kind of
experience you know what have you seen
they're like what are your kind of best
practices or ways that developers have
used both you and some of the community
in the space and like what is good and
what is kind of bad yes so I mean I
started out back in 2015 when I got kind
of into the NDA club for supercell and
at that time there was only 11 people I
was the 11th we're in a small little
skype group with not a lot of
organization I mean they did a good job
obviously they were one of the first
major
developers to kind of embrace youtubers
but at that point now in just three
short years we've grown to over 200
people content creators and it's it's
it's run in a lot of different ways but
you know with the big companies that
already have that ecosystem of content
creators it's really easy right so you
we have those relationships they say hey
a new games coming out and boom we're
there that's it you know but two pillars
of supercell has always been even before
they blew up with heyday and clash of
clans in 2014 and 15 they they've never
paid anybody to cover their games a and
they've never given in-game resources
which are two really strong values to
have and I think that it's really easy
to say that and really hard to execute
on a community or a content creator
strategy without using those two
resources but they've always had the
mentality that we just want people to
organically play our game or cover our
game without having to give them stuff
to do it so instead of that they've
tried to create ways to grow influencers
channels who they work with as kind of
the carrot and then they'll want to
cover the game because they'll get so
many views so I think that the best ways
to try to build your own your own
community of content creators if you're
a developer in my opinion just from
seeing so many companies pay so much
money to my colleagues and me the offers
that we get you know for one video is
can triple our monthly YouTube income
you know so I don't think that that's
money necessarily well-spent although it
might acquire more users as you know
advertising on Facebook say but I do
think that the best strategy in my
opinions and I've consulted with other
developers who've done this is to kind
of pick small to mid to burrs who you're
a real big fan of their production
they're you know that you feel like they
jive well with what you're trying to
portray to the public and try to help
them grow in the biggest incentive for
me especially when I was a smaller
youtuber is to share their content in
game especially direct especially kind
of revolving around updates because what
that does is it sends your traffic from
the game to the content creators YouTube
channel and that incentive incentivizes
us to
to cover the game beyond just that one
that one sponsored video so I think that
moving a step further than that having
live events I've gone to travel the
world been lucky enough and like I said
it's surreal to me because you know I'm
a 35 year old I was a mail carrier for
13 years and you know just not much
going on you know in terms of don't
discredit mailer couriers you're already
doing production quality of my ride
myself into the ground but but seriously
it's just ultimately it's just the fact
that there's a big thirst I think for
for content creators and community and I
think that neither the content creators
nor the third parties who work with the
developers and content creators or the
developers really utilize it in a great
way would you say then that kind of the
community at some point takes on a
little bit of a life of its own you know
and kind of transcends maybe even the
updates or keeps you know the the
valleys kind of alive while peak updates
are kind of you know in the works
absolutely yeah for sure you know and
I've worked with a smaller developer and
we recruited just two youtubers one with
4,000 subscribers and one with 9000
subscribers and we put them into their
game just kind of like I talked to you
about earlier and now they're
organically covering the game and that's
like the best case scenario because then
you can kind of grow together and then
your players know where to find
information about updates about whatever
content that you want to highlight and
it's kind of a symbiotic relationship
rather than just a transactional
relationship sure sure so yeah we're
joking about this before again either
flattering pic picked a better picture
on this one but you know I think it's
really interesting when talking about
like you know the day in the life of
someone who kind of does this as your
career right like like you said you you
were delivering mail for like almost
over a decade and then you kind of just
recently within the past six months like
eight months or six months transition to
doing content creation full-time like
what is a day you know was a day and of
life of you kind of look like like what
is a good day and what's a bad day and
how can you know developers and how can
like the game publishers kind of like
help with making your days better that's
a big question Lester I think that my
life is certainly not
anything that exciting just I go to
office I rented office space and I just
work on my video early get that all set
and then you know of course leaving a
government job albeit not the best one
in the world but just a steady
government job for something as as
insecure or at least it feels so
insecure as a YouTube channel it's a big
step so what I've done is basically put
is as many exited every basket as I
possibly could so I do consulting and I
do I work for a couple startup companies
also I guess a community manager for a
game coming out soon so I think that
what I've tried to do is just provide
that that conduit from the the
influencers the developers and I've just
spend most my time just networking
really you know so as far as what a
developer can can do for somebody like
me as I just think that I think that we
need to kind of have a healthier
relationship developers and content
creators because I think that we both
have a lot to offer but for some reason
like I said before there's just that
missing link some somewhere and I don't
think that right now I don't think the
current system really works for anybody
you know be honest how long do you spend
responding to comments on your YouTube
channel an hour actually I spent an hour
day which is probably 59 minutes more
than anybody else does at least because
it takes a lot of time and but I found
that you know this is kind of apropos of
nothing I guess but I find that to get
good YouTube engagement if you train
your viewers that you're going to
respond in the first half an hour hour
hour and a half however long that is it
creates a real huge spike in community
around your channel so I think that
that's really key to my micro strategy
in YouTube so kind of we've touched on
us in many different ways but you know
when I was kind of looking at the
landscape of some of these games that
you know even the past two years have
kind of exploded and I look at the
volume of games and then I also look at
the volume of YouTube channels that have
sprouted up I think I was pulling some
stats before this I think currently
there's around 39 or 40 YouTube channels
this year that breached the 1 million
subscriber mark so huge kind of new
audience right where mobile first or you
know mobile gaming creators are also
attracting a
viewing first you know audience what do
you think you know there is there like a
prescriptive recipe for success I think
you kind of maybe touched on it when
talking about going for the middle to
your channels but do you see any kind of
pattern that tends to work you know more
frequently than than ones that don't
yeah like you said I touched on like
some of the things that I feel
passionately about is is I do feel like
just paying for videos is is just not a
good strategy I mean you know Pokemon go
vainglory supercell games a small
minority of companies who don't do that
you know there's there's sure there's a
lot of others but I just don't think
it's a great strategy I think that
having live events and developing
community like that and maybe paying for
somebody to make an appearance is okay I
think there's and then there's there's
other ways to do things as well like if
you reach out to a content creator they
might not even know you're a game so how
are you gonna get them to the point
where you want to show off your game
without giving them at least getting
game resources but you know some things
that some strategies that some companies
that I've worked with have used is just
giving them a stock footage and then
allowing them to maybe play the game on
an account that's progressed a little
bit further but not giving them that as
a resource because they I think valuing
your own int games in-game economy to
the fact that you just won't give it out
from people that promote you is is
important but of course that's probably
an unpopular opinion because it's what
everybody does right now at least and
everybody you know might as well all my
emails are filled with you so I do think
that the missing link here is that you
want people to cover your game
organically but they won't do that
unless they get the views so how do you
kind of how do you kind of remedy that
yeah it's interesting kind of thing
because you know like I noticed
especially to the amount of views
generated I think between the large
updates on games is often like what do
you do when there's not enough content
to be created around right I think they
they kind of touched on it before it's
like you want to launch your game with a
lot of content but then when you also
think about the long term cycle of a
game what happens to you as a creator
when there isn't like how long would you
say that threshold is before you start
being like man I got to move on to a new
game or there's not enough content to be
made here yeah it's tough from from our
perspective just as a developer
perspective is just that you can only do
a video daily I've have over almost
1,300 videos but you can only do videos
daily on the game doing the same thing
for so long unless you really have a
unique set of something that you're
bringing to the table you know so I have
my own kind of flavor but you're right
we're always looking for that next game
that's going to take off and the problem
is that boxes out all the small games
that are worth looking into you know so
I don't know the perfect solution other
than almost like flip-flops where where
you said maybe some of the developers or
publishers should look at the middle
tier I think so creator is it's almost
like you you might be able to find a
niche by looking at some of them I think
so I think that if I was going to
develop a game and I want to create it
give a great strategy for getting
content creators on board I would try to
reach out to you someone who has a
little bit of influence inside the
ecosystem and then have them almost
recruit other content creators who are
smaller to bring onboard you know that's
that's kind of my favorite strategy of
growing a community or even taking
someone who's maybe an influencer in
your game maybe you don't have content
creators who cover your game but you
have forums of passionate players maybe
just kind of mentoring and paying hey
we'll buy you whatever a PC if it if it
takes it you know we'll buy you an
elgato a to a smaller scale and you can
and will share your content will help
you grow together like I think that's a
great strategy to use and it doesn't pay
it doesn't pay those immediate dividends
like a paid promotion does but and maybe
there is a time and a place for a paid
promotion but I just don't think it's a
it's a good you know community building
strategy or just instant downloads you
know so moving on I think you know like
a big question there this is kind of a
loaded slide but like kind of what is in
your eyes the future of mobile gaming I
think when I look at each of these I
think of a new you know supermassive
game IP deck that could horizon and have
huge implications in the West I think
you know supercell obviously has brawl
stars coming out that could be
interesting as far as the size of the
company it's coming from again you know
there's an eSports aspect that to
consider right as far as extending
mobile games IP with something like the
crown championship and then
lastly kind of talking about devices and
hardware like you know phones that have
better kind of built in both cameras and
and hardware and usability and screen
size and all these things and how do you
really you know you can jump into any
one of these like where do you really
see some of these futures going geez
like you said it is a big big question
but me personally I think that a lot of
the the global market has been devalued
based on the advertising dollars or
various other factors but I think that
it's maybe a mistake just from a I've
never seen a more passionate base of
players and I've seen in say Brazil the
Portuguese spanish-speaking communities
or India you know I think that that's a
untapped audience to some extent and
even in in countries less fortunate
everybody still has a mobile device or a
lot of people do so I think that there's
millions of players who can be who are
basically there's a big appetite for
these games in those markets but people
just don't market to them because that's
not what advertisers want oftentimes so
I think that the future of mobile gaming
is definitely global and I think that
capturing that global market should be
it should be a priority at least in my
mind I mean I can tell you that covering
you know covering clash around supercell
games as I do there's no more rabid fan
base there's no more faster growing fan
base than those Spanish speaking and in
Portuguese speaking communities even
Germany to a lesser extent in India and
Malaysia Philippines like these are all
markets that the appetite is so huge for
these mobile games so I think that just
capitalizing on the global scale and not
devaluing it too much just because of of
advertising and and the bottom line I
think that that could be a mistake I
think that the future is global you know
I mean these games are all have such
huge potential arena valor with strike
of Kings and China which is the number
one game last like two years incredible
I mean the government made instituted
laws where you you you know it's
limiting the amount of play that you
could have on the game a mobile game
which is crazy so that's been rebranded
to arena valor and as launching in
November
you know see
which is the clash Royale global
championship kind of proves that that
mobile can be an eSport and we'll see
you know just how just how far they can
take that but it is a 1 million dollar
contest in London next month so it's
playing a mobile game which is something
we've never seen before
yeah I know we're kind of discussing
this at lunch kind of like a revenue
first model between developers you know
having a lot of hooks in order to you
know incentivize purchase and whatnot
and how that also fits in the same
conversation of fair competitive play
right like making sure that there's an
equal playing field that it's embracing
kind of every man you know like a woman
to play yeah additively
do you have any opinions about that or
how you see the balance between you know
revenue driving games which is purely
competitive games because I think it's
it's hard to you know really breach the
gap of eSports without really addressing
that yeah it's a people way smarter than
me have spent so much time thinking
about this and I think that it's at
least from supercells
vantage point again who I work with
closely in Tencent as well it's you know
making sure that you value the casual
gamer as you know paramount to your
success and at the same time building
you know that infrastructure for
competitive gaming kind of as a I don't
know an afterthought at this point I
wish it was more than that but that's
just kind of what I've seen and maybe
vainglory being the one exception right
now mobile gaming which they're really
full throttle on to the competitive
scene not so much on the casual scene
but then I think that ultimately there's
a reason they're not as quite as
successful as the other big games
because they've kind of honed in so so
surely on those sure so I kind of like
you know this is kind of geared towards
you just because of the like the start
of your channels been on clash of clans
you've evolved in the past few years
towards towards clash Royale and I mean
this is like can you can take it a few
different ways right like as far as
community building not just you know
like gameplay mechanics or releases or
anything else like that you know who do
you really think as far as philosophy
those can really step up to the plate
yeah so I don't without naming any like
certain developers I think that creating
that community is definitely so
so important right I think that like we
talked about throughout this whole this
whole discussion is to not at least try
to get content creators on board with
your game bill they'll patch up some of
those holes that we talked about between
updates between major features that are
being added to the game they'll help you
and they'll they'll create a community
around your game and having people talk
about your game is awesome so I think
that the next company that can it's a
it's a - it's a you know it's a
multi-pronged I guess answer but you
know developing community working with
content creators and making an awesome
game i mean obviously the game has to be
good for people to ultimately want to
play it and you know it's it's I think
everybody as a content creator
everybody's always on the lookout for
who's gonna be the next supercell or
who's gonna be that next big developer
to give us viability for you know
because we're looking for long term
viability as a content creator just as
developers are - so what is the life of
a game right now that's something that
no one even knows exactly the answer
what is the life of a mobile game clash
of clans has been going strong for five
years but is that an aberration or is
that the norm you know it's it's it's
difficult and I know I've really dodged
the question but I don't I don't know
who's gonna be the next supercell I
think that I think that hopefully given
platforms like YouTube and given
platforms like twitch and stuff like
that that you know developers can
somehow work better with content
creators moving forward to kind of make
multiple supercells instead of just one
or two you know so who do you think's
gonna do supercell Leicester that's like
they'll turn it back on yeah well I
appreciate that thought and I think you
know like from from a content creation
standpoint it clearly relies on kind of
replayability the ability to kind of
like seed content so that there's always
freshness right and I think it's it's a
lot about kind of developing things
outside of just like the standard
out-of-the-box gameplay right like how
can you evolve that what are some you
know institutionalized ways of thinking
of game modes that can be completely
reversed right I think different modes
and using derivative IP and kind of
figuring out different ways to play with
that I've noticed give
content creators a lot more to bite on
and also modes which lead towards like
unreachable goals or like really hard
goal it's a good one that's a good one
right like I think that like no one
thought that anyone would get to you
know ex top leaderboard or ex wins or to
some status and I think building and
kind of mechanics which you know the
person will play every single day and
also record every single day because I
think you want to get an audience who's
inherited in your journey of doing
something right and I think that with
you YouTube creators or even streamers
having a goal is like you kind of coming
full circle that was kind of like what
do you want to do at the end of the
series right are you doing a series on
competitive play are you doing a series
on tips are you doing a series on
anything else right like what is the
start and what's the finish I think for
developers I've personally noticed that
like setting these goals like
unreachable goals also within games help
for that yeah I think that you hit the
nail on the head it's coming from you
know a bit of an MMO PC background side
I love the grind and even if people
don't say they don't love the grind I
think they deep down they do it
it makes the game sticky and it makes
you want to stay around to kind of
compete yeah well I think we're out of
time here I'm gonna kick it over to Dan
Atkins he's over at the day dream team
so he'll talk a little bit about
building VR experiences within apps and
games cool
you